what does it feel like um
to bomb in stand-up comedy like to fail
maybe the psychology of it first like
just take me through it because you were
talking about being
uh outnumbered in a fight just being
beat up very similar
uh by the way this is like a no eye
contact off yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's great it's kind of nice to be
with my people
um but yeah she had a paper to look at
her
i'm going
i got a good sweet spot right there yes
yeah it's uh it's a nightmare but it's
part of it you know it's it's
it's the it's the validation too is the
worst part like because you know
whenever you do comedy and kill you can
be a great comic but even david tell
these brilliant guys they feel like
they're getting you feel like you're
getting away with something i don't have
a day job i'm telling jokes for a living
i'm talking about my dick up here and
they're [ __ ] loving me and they call
me a genius and all this i'm talking
about my sack yeah you know and uh and
it's great it makes people happy and
it's funny but
uh that bombing when you bomb you go
your first thought is like yeah you're
right at first you're like
[ __ ] you guy what you don't like this
[ __ ] and then you just start going in
you're like yeah maybe it isn't that
good maybe they're right i do suck i
knew i sucked i should become a mailman
you know and uh it stinks and it feel
you feel alone and you feel like you
wasted their time and then you're like
what was i thinking i could be a
comedian what the [ __ ] who am i you know
eddie murphy what am i doing here so uh
it's a lot of just spiraling out of
horrible thoughts
but i also love that it hurts so bad
bombing [ __ ] hurts because now now
everybody doesn't do it i think a lot
more people could do comedy probably and
figure it out but the bombing is so
brutal that it keeps uh
one time i went to minneapolis i was
like this is a great city i mean the sun
is shining why isn't the city like
packed and they're like because the
winners are so bad and we love it
because it keeps everybody out and i
feel the same about comedy the bombs are
so brutal
i've had bombs where i'm in i'm in bed
i'm just staring at the ceiling like
what the [ __ ] was that like you have
ptsd i bombed at an arena once 20 000
people i did 30 minutes to silence
so it's not just like one joke fails
they start piling on like it's
irrecoverable yes and one joke failing
is very common like a lot of audience
don't even notice like that bomb because
you get you know you got so many jokes
in a row you can sandwich a good one
then a bad one then a good one but when
you bomb it's almost like they chose we
don't like you
nothing you say will redeem yourself
and uh it's hard to get out of it's like
being pulled down by your hair you can't
get back i can't win this fight no
matter what
can you like get him back by
acknowledging like the alpha in the room
that like that helps but they're still
gonna go and that was funny when he made
fun of it but he sucks he's still stuck
he still sucks that's the worst part
you're going no this is good you guys
just don't like me just because you
don't like me doesn't mean i'm bad
yeah i like going to open mics a lot
just just listening because
first of all i think the audience in
open mic at least the ones i've been to
is uh mostly i guess other comedians
it's it or like at least people who
don't seem to want to laugh at anything
and so
i just love it because it's human nature
and perseverance that is best but here's
comedians like clearly
uh this is mostly in austin they have a
dream
like why would you get up there right
like maybe some weird you know
new year's resolution [ __ ] but for
the most part it's people who want to be
comedian like a lot of the open mikers
are people who have clearly have done
this for quite a long time yeah like at
least a year two maybe five years
and
they're often not very funny
and um
the just bombing in front of
an audience of like 20 where they're
just sitting there
like almost like mocking them with their
eyes or maybe
and i don't know and they still push
through they still they still like as if
they're doing an arena and everybody's
laughing yeah they still they still got
that energy trying almost like to an
audience
that doesn't exist like an audience of
their dreams because i guess you have to
do that to keep the energy of the act
going and it's just so beautiful to
watch wow then try it it's uh and also
the what happens
open mic i don't know five minutes
whatever they do
they you know walk off and that walk
back you know off stage
and like you can't who do they look at
like what do you look at do you make eye
contact with people do you you look at
your phone you look at your feet you
just zone out you kind of
kind of go white you know you just hear
white noise and go out it's it's tough
but you gotta you need a little
a little delusion to be a comedian to
get into it it takes a little bit of
delusion like you think you can do this
you know you got 10 years ahead of you
of hell and you're up for this
and you know most comics we see a
horrible crowd and we see our friend
bomb and we go yeah he's bombing but
i'll get him i'll get him and then
you don't get them
but
that's that's
human nature too it's like i they don't
like him but they'll like me and you
need a little of that to keep going as a
comedian but you don't want too much
delusion because then you're a psycho
but
you need a little
well a psycho could be good for a comedy
that's true too a lot of psychos
you